en el último vídeo les mostré la
transformada de la plaza de té o podemos
verla como té a la potencia 1 es igual a
1 sobre ese cuadrado si asumimos que ese
es mayor que 0
en este vídeo vamos a ver qué podemos
generalizar esto intentando obtener la
transformada de la plaza dt a la n donde
n es cualquier potencia entera mayor que
0 por lo que es cualquier entero
positivo mayor que cero así que
intentemos lo sabemos por nuestra
definición de transformada de la plaza
que la transformada de la plaza de t a
la n es igual a la integral desde cero
al infinito desde cero al infinito
nuestra función bueno déjame escribo que
a la n por y este es solo la definición
de la transformada a la menos s de
diferencial de t y parecido a cuando
hicimos esta transformada de la plaza tu
intuición debería de decir
y hay que usar integración por partes y
lo mostré en el último vídeo siempre el
olvido pero lo acabo de grabar por lo
que ahora lo recuerdo entonces la
integración por parte solo nos dice que
la integral de un b prima es igual a o
por b menos la integral de sé que esta
es una clase de intercambio por lo que
tenemos a prima o prima por b
este es sólo nuestra fórmula de
integración por partes si alguna vez la
olvidas
puedes deducir la en 30 segundos lo hice
en el último vídeo porque hace mucho que
no la usaba y tuve que volverla a
deducir así que apliquemos la así que
como quieren hacer nuestra be prima
siempre es bueno utilizar nuestra
función exponencial porque es más fácil
de obtener su integral así que esta es
mi prima en este caso nuestra vez la
integral de esto entonces tenemos
al menos siete sobre menos s si tomamos
la derivada de esto menos s dividida
entre menos s se cancela y te queda eso
y luego si hacemos si hacemos nuestra o
si hacemos está igual av
cuál es nuestra prima o prima va a ser
n porte a la n 1 muy bien apliquemos la
integración por partes entonces esto va
a ser igual a o por b y este a la n
entonces este a la n esta es nuestra por
p que es déjame escribir esto entonces
es menos hay un menos allí déjame pongo
un menos ahí pongámoslo en el mismo
color menos estamos escribiendo esto era
la menos 7
sobre ese entonces ese es nuestro
término u por ver déjame lo hago más
claro entonces este término de aquí es
este término de aquí y por supuesto voy
a tener que evaluar esto desde cero a
infinito
déjame escribir eso desde cero al
infinito y puedo poner un pequeño
corchete y yo algo para que sepas que
tienes que evaluar eso ya eso le tenemos
que restar la integral
y deja recuerdo nuestros límites de cero
a infinito o prima o prima s n porte a
la n menos uno
esa es nuestra prima por p por menos
mientras pongamos este menos aquí afuera
entonces es menos
al menos st sobre ese y después de todo
eso por supuesto tenemos nuestro
diferencial de té
tenemos un menos menos por lo que éstas
se convierten en positivos y veamos si
podemos simplificar esto un poco tenemos
nuestra transformada de la plaza de té a
la n es igual a esto evaluando en
infinito y evaluado en cero así que cuál
es el límite de esto cuando te se
aproxima al infinito cuando te se
aproxima a infinito
este término podrías decir como este
término puede volverse muy grande y
hablé sobre esto en el último vídeo pero
este término disminuye su poder porque
tenemos a la menos infinito si asumimos
que ese es mayor que cero entonces si
ese es mayor que cero
este término va a ganar y llegar a cero
mucho más rápido que lo que este término
irá a infinito por lo que cuando
evaluamos esto en infinito
obtener
y luego le vamos a restar este término
evaluado en 0 esto evaluado en 0 si
evaluamos el 0 tenemos menos 0 a la n
por ea la menos s por 0 sobre s éste se
vuelve un 0 también todo este término
evaluado de 0 a infinito es 0 lo que es
algo muy conveniente para nosotros y
luego vamos a tener este otro término de
aquí así que saquemos los términos
constantes
está n estã s son constantes son
constantes con respecto a t y tenemos
más n sobre s por la integral desde cero
a infinito d
a la n menos uno por el ala menos ese
diferencial de t ahora esto debería de
parecerte muy familiar esto debería de
verse cuál es la definición de la
transformada de la plaza la transformada
desde la plaza de cualquier función es
igual a la integral de 0 a infinito de
esa función por el ala menos 7
diferencial de t tenemos aquí la ala -
-siete diferencial de t
estamos tomando el intervalo de 0 a
infinito por lo que toda esta integral
es igual a la transformada de la plaz de
esto
dt a la n 1 así de fácil
gracias a que este término fue 0
simplificamos las cosas tenemos que
la transformada de la plaza
a la n es igual a porque todo esto es 0
es igual a n sobre s que está ahí por
esta integral de aquí que nos acabamos
de dar cuenta de que era la transformada
de la plaza de t a la n menos 1 bueno
esta es una bonita simplificación
podemos ahora obtener la transformada de
la plaza de una potencia mayor en
términos de la potencia 1 pero esto aún
no me da una fórmula generalizada vamos
a ver si podemos utilizar esto con esta
información para obtener una fórmula
generalizada por lo que la transformada
de la plaza de sol o te déjame escribir
eso acá abajo escribí eso al inicio del
problema tenemos la transformada de la
plaza puedo escribir esto como 'the a la
1 o solo te es igual a 1 sobre s al
cuadrado donde s es mayor que 0 donde s
es mayor a 0
qué pasa si tomamos la transformada de
la plaza la transformada de la plaza de
t al cuadrado o podemos sólo utilizar la
fórmula de aquí la transformada de la
plaza de t al cuadrado es igual a 2
entre s por la transformada de la plaza
de t de solo te a la 12 menos uno
entonces es por la transformada de la
plaza de t a la 1 y ya sabemos qué es
eso esto es igual a 2 sobre s por eso
por 1 sobre s al cuadrado que es igual a
2 sobre s al cubo interesante veamos si
podemos hacer otro cuál es la
transformada de la plaza de t al cubo
bien pues sólo necesitamos utilizar esta
fórmula de aquí es n sobre s en este
caso en estrés
entonces es 3 sobre s por la
transformada de la plaza de t a la n 1
que esté al cuadrado sabemos que la
transformada en la plaza de esta era
esta es sólo está justo allí es igual a
3 / s por por esta cosa y voy de hecho a
escribir la de esta manera porque creo
que es interesante escribir los
numeradores por 2 x 1 sobre s sobre s al
cuadrado lo que es podemos escribirlo
como 3 factorial sobre s a la cuarta
potencia s a la cuarta potencia hagamos
otro creo que ya están entendiendo lo
que está pasando
transformada de la plaza de té a la
cuarta potencia es que es igual a 4
sobre s por la transformada de la plaza
de t al cubo y esto es sólo 4 sobre s
por esto entonces es 4 sobre s por tres
factores sobre s a la 4 y ahora 4 por 3
factorial es 4 factorial sobre s a la
quinta potencia así que puedes solo
obtener la idea general el principio
general podemos probar esto por
inducción es casi trivial después de
todo lo que hemos hecho la transformada
de la plaza la transformada de la plaza
a la n sigo a la enee factorial n
factorial sobre s a la n 1 lo probamos
directamente con este caso de aquí
verdad este es uno factorial sobre s a
la 1 más 1 y luego si sabemos que si
sabemos que es verdad para este sabemos
que va a ser verdad para el siguiente
incremento la prueba de inducción es
casi obvia pero puedes incluso verlo
basándote en esto si necesitas obtener
la transformada de la placeta a la 10
puedes seguir haciendo esto una y otra
vez pero creo que puedes ver el patrón
claramente de todas maneras espero que
haya sido un ejemplo lindo por sí mismo
ya saben fuera del hecho de que será
útil poder obtener transformadas de
laplace directas e inversas pero este es
un resultado muy lindo la transformada
de la plaz dt a la n donde n es algún
entero mayor que 0
es igual a n factorial sobre s a la n 1
donde s es también mayor que 0 esa fue
una suposición que tuvimos que hacer al
inicio cuando tomamos nuestros límites
de cuando t se aproxima al infinito de
todas maneras espero hayan encontrado
esto útil